Спів може наблизити людей до Бога,
у цьому переконана Софія Фалькович.
І це стало її покликанням.
Домівкою для неї став Париж,
але куди б Софію не занесла доля,
усюди можна співати в синагозі.
Вона - канторка, або як частіше кажуть в Україні "хаззан" -
людина, яка веде службу та співає молитви,
в той час як рабин читає проповідь.
І саме тому вона сьогодні - у Фрайбурзі
Музика у синагозі, голос співця -
усе це напряму промовляє до моєї душі.
Я відчуваю себе частиною усього цього
і вже бачу, як саме я зможу розвинути літургію.
У свій власний спосіб промовляти молитви - як жінка.
Для ортодоксальних іудеїв це справжня революція.
Оскільки роль головного співця молитов у синагозі,
до якого за традицією приєднується вся громада,
історично - чоловіча справа.
Софія Фалькович хотіла б змінити традицію ще й тому,
що вона сама - людина світу.
Народилася у Москві у мистецькій родині,
виросла - у Берліні. Там же,
а згодом в Єрусалимі, отримала освіту кантора.
Вона хоче співати, молитися та не зважати на обставини.
Кожна людина від народження має талант,
і наше завдання в життя – розвинути цей талант.
Кожен співець має власний стиль,
власний шлях і ним повинен йти.
У таких ортодоксальних громадах, як у Фрайбурзі,
зазвичай, жінкам не дозволяється співати під час служби.
За Торою жінка має дбати про родину,
і тому не повинна молитися так багато, як чоловік,
розповідає Моше Хайон, теперішній кантор у Фрайбурзі.
Жінка як співець молитов у синагозі -
для багатьох віруючих євреїв це означає, що світ перевернувся.
Жінки дуже гарно співають.
Але жіночий голос може не дати чоловікам зосередитись у молитві.
Вони починають слухати красу жіночого голосу,
або розглядати саму жінку.
І тоді в них з'являються думки, які не мають нічого спільного з молитвою.
Зміни приходять маленькими кроками.
Це девіз Ірини Кац, яка очолює іудейську громаду у Фрайбурзі.
Саме вона запросила Софію Фалькович.
Спершу Софія приїхала і виступила з концертом.
Нині їй дозволили співати на службі. Але тільки для жінок.
Цього разу жінки не повинні сидіти за перегородкою подалі від чоловіків
Вони можуть бути спереду -
там, де зазвичай моляться чоловіки.
Що я хотіла б побачити в наших жінках,
то це справжнє розуміння молитви. Що не завжди трапляється.
І щоб жінки, можливо, пізніше, коли вони ще і ще почують молитву,
зосередилися на тексті з Біблії, з Тори.
Така головна мета богослужіння,
яке ми влаштовуємо вперше.
У ліберальних єврейських громадах така практика
давно стала буденністю, розповідає Софія.
Там вона може і перед чоловіками співати.
В наш час це має стає нормальною річчю.
Зараз жінка може бути юристкою або вчителькою -
тепер це вже не питання.
Але релігія - остання сфера, яку чоловіки ще утримують
і в якій вони не мають бажання посунутись.
Але все ж таки запрошень приїхати та співати на богослужіннях
стає дедалі більше. Софія сподівається, що незабаром
зможе знайти собі постійне місце в синагозі.
Я не маю бажання постійно доводити, що я це можу.
Хочу просто співати,
не сперечатися, чи можна мені це робити.
М’яка революція - така мета Софії Фалькович
і в цьому вона повністю покладається
на силу переконання свого голосу.